What we need to see here in the graph is a bunch of triangles. So, if we let
each side length, or each of these distances that we're looking for, be the
hypotenuse of a right triangle, then we can as we've done so many times before,
use the Pythagorean theorem to find the length of that side. Conveniently, since
we're using graph paper, made up of these little tiny squares, we have right
angles all over the place. That made drawing these right triangles super simple.
If you look at the opposite ends of one of these side lengths, we can just draw
lines along the lines that are already given to us by the graph paper. And the
intersect to help us form the right triangle. Then, we just need to figure out
the length of each of these legs for each of these triangles. Let's look at leg
AB as an example for how to deal with the other three triangles on here. We need
to find out the length of either of the two shorter legs in order to find out
the hypotenuse. So, we could just count one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Seven is the length of this side. We'll do the same thing for this side. This is
five. In looking at this modified version of the Pythagorean theorem, we can
just say that the length of AB, this hypotenuse, is the square root of 7 squared
plus 5 squared. Simplifying that gives us the square root of 74. Once we find
the lengths of the legs of all of the other right triangles, calculating their
hypotenuses is also easy.
And so, at long last, here are our final answers. The length of AB is the square
root of 74, BC, square root of 180, CD is the square root of 40, and DA is the
square root of 130.